pour dire les choses à droite il y a à
mon avis autant d'homosexuel qu'à gauche
Philippe Ménard mesdames messieurs vous
le connaissez pas
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
vous arrivez
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme dans les sites comme
exactement bien vu philippe était
adorable quand on est avec Marianne on
passait dans les loges il disait il y a
plein de jolies filles ici maman vous
êtes en train de tourner votre
chien qui devient anarchiste
on peut tout à fait être
homosexuels
mais ceci dit vous les choisissez très
bien et très bien les filles
bien alors Philippe Ménard on va vous
présenter
vous êtes vous êtes un élu de l'UDF et
je pense que vous êtes le premier si je
me trompe pas le premier élu de la
droite à faire votre coming out
c'est-à-dire à dire que vous êtes vous
avez été le premier à dire que vous êtes
homosexuel oui jusque là il y avait
beaucoup de gens à gauche il y avait eu
de la Noé il y avait eu Françoise
Gaspard il y a eu le maire à la Barrère
le maire de Pau et ben la dure
il l'a jamais dit
on sent que ça perce quand même je pense
que c'est une passion rentrée de votre
part d'affi et puis
il a deux idoles en politique c'est un
c'est vrai alors c'est vraiment c'est
mon moment
c'est lui qui t'a fait c'est lui qui m'a
fait
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois que la loi est passée
les homosexuels ont apporté beaucoup à
la culture à la civilisation de tout
temps ça a toujours existé il y a pas de
raison d'avoir des préjugés
avec nationalité
en gros Christine Boutin n'a rien à
faire à l'UDF alors Philippe bouste
Blazy quand vous lui avez dit ça a été
un peu paniqué à la tribune il sait plus
très bien quoi dire il a dit m'attendait
c'est moi qui ai fait le préservatif à 1
franc
alors oui c'est vrai mais enfin quand
même vous avez quand même envoyé
Christine Boutin voilà et alors il a
quand même mis un peu d'eau dans son
bain Philippe de Blazy il a dit la
pensée de Christine Boutin est à moitié
honnête à moitié homophobe ce qui prouve
que Philippe de Blasi est un vrai centre
triste là on en a la preuve avec cette
phrase alors la preuve aussi c'est que
Christine Boutin la dernière fois qu'on
a parlé de du PACS à l'Assemblée elle a
eu 5 heures et cette fois-ci il a eu
cinq minutes donc apparemment Votre
action n'a pas complètement
inutile alors vous êtes à l'idée depuis
l'âge de 19 ans
vous êtes homosexuel c'est difficile
dans une communauté comme Barsac avec
2000 habitants non c'est difficile
d'autant plus que depuis un certain
nombre de mois
suivant les milieux et surtout depuis
les dernières élections régionales en
1998 élections auxquelles je participais
puisque j'étais candidat sur la liste de
Jacques Valade qui était le président
sortant du conseil régional et donc à la
suite de ces élections tous un petit peu
précipités pendant la campagne on m'a
menacé de distribution de tracts dans ma
commune dans les boîtes aux lettres de
ma commune
traque sur lesquelles devaient figurer
un certain nombre de détails
croustillants sur ma vie privée et ma
vie professionnelle
ce à quoi comme je suis un garçon un
petit peu émotif j'ai un petit peu
paniqué et je me suis dit que à ce
moment-là la meilleure des défenses
c'était l'attaque
que il n'était pas question pour moi de
céder à ce genre de pratique et donc
bien évidemment j'ai maintenu ma
candidature aux élections dans la nuit
du 11 au 12 août vous dormez pas et le
12 au matin votre décision est prise
vous dites cette fois cette fois j'ai
pensé à moi parce que c'est vrai que
votre travail d'élu vous oblige à
beaucoup penser aux autres vous
impliquer pour les autres pardon je vais
aller à la pêche non cette fois j'ai
pensé à moi je vais plus tricher vous
décidez donc de rendre public la chose
de façon effectivement de protéger de
ces menaces par exemple des fois vous
écoutiez votre portable comme ça il y
avait des coups de feu
c'est quand même facile la région où il
tire sur les tourterelles vous me direz
en même temps ceci dit il a pas tout à
fait tort parce que je me suis
effectivement posé la question première
quinzaine d'août de savoir si il n'était
pas mieux pour moi de continuer à
tricher et de continuer à être caché et
en ce sens de fuir tout ce qui pouvait
faire en sorte que j'étais pas bien dans
ma peau c'est à dire j'ai effectivement
envisagé de quitter la mairie de
démissionner de quitter la commune dans
laquelle
je suis arrivé j'avais trois jours donc
bon j'ai quand même passé près de 30 ans
de ma vie et je me suis dit je vais
aller voler vers d'autres horizons et je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails mais
je suis issu d'une famille dans laquelle
il y a 7 enfants dans un milieu agricole
puisque mes parents sont viticulteurs
étaient au courant depuis l'âge de 18
ans et eux finalement ça leur avait
jamais posé spécialement de problèmes si
vous voulez
quand on entend ils auront des petits
enfants de toute façon
il y a eu certaines événements dans dans
ma famille qui
qui m'ont amené un jour
manger failli perdre ma mère à deux
reprises et je voulais pas que si elle
partait je ne voulais pas ne pas lui
dire qu'elle était ma vie et donc un
soir je j'étais étudiant à Dax et donc
je l'ai appelé et nous allons profiter
le weekend qui a suivi pour pour
discuter de ma vie pour discuter de ce
que j'avais l'intention de faire et donc
c'est à ce moment-là que je lui ai
révélé que maintenant je préfère
maintenant elle va elle va mieux alors
Philippe donc vous annoncez au conseil
municipal ça a pas dû être alors là
aussi j'ai donc le matin j'ai appelé le
maire et je lui ai dit je souhaiterais
que tu organises une réunion des
adjoints avant le conseil municipal
parce que j'ai quelque chose d'important
à vous annoncer et donc je leur ai
annoncé que je leur confirmé ce que tout
le monde disait c'est à dire
qu'effectivement j'étais homosexuel et
comme nous avions une réunion du conseil
municipal le soir j'ai demandé au maire
qu'à l'issue du conseil municipal elle
puisse réunir le groupe majoritaire pour
que nous puissions en discuter parce que
je souhaitais que tout le monde le sache
en même temps et que tout le monde
éventuellement puisse donner son avis et
qu'on puisse en discuter tranquillement
moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est que
par exemple vous vous êtes là vous êtes
UDF vous Patrick vous êtes RPR et donc à
l'intérieur déjà vous les faire
l'association vous voulez faire la vous
voulez comme j'étais à la refaire
l'alliance qui a tellement bien marché
entre le RPR et le démocratie libérale à
l'époque enfin l'UDF et ensuite
démocratie libérale vous n'êtes pas
d'accord là-dessus vous vous pensez
parce que lui il pense Philippe vous
pensez vous que la droite aurait dû
voter le PACS je sais pas si ce n'est
pas le fait que des parlementaires de
droite n'est pas voté pour le PACS qui
me gêne c'est pas ça ce qui me gêne et
ce qui
m'a mené à faire les déclarations que
j'ai faites c'est les comportements de
certains parlementaires de la droite
moi je suis un être humain je fais de la
politique mais je suis un être humain et
donc quand je constate certains
débordements verbaux et je suis blessé
d'autant plus quand je suis concerné et
quand je vois des parlementaires qui
pour passer à la télévision vite fait au
journal télévisé se permettent de dire
les [__] je leur pisse à l'arrêt ou
quand
c'est un UDF mais de dire son nom Samuel
quand on a un sénateur qui par contre
interpelle compare le PACS à un projet
de contamination sidaïque quand on a
madame Boutin qui est dans mon parti qui
participe à des manifestations dans
lesquelles on peut lire des pancartes
les [__] au bûcher ça ça me choque ça
me choque en tant que moi les [__]
[Rires]
c'est bien parce que l'ambiance
ça ça me chauffe et ce qui a motivé
[Musique]
pierre chez vous il y a un célèbre homme
politique de votre partie dont nous ne
citrons pas le nom parce qu'on n'est pas
des balances qui lui est homosexuel mais
elle est défiler et elle est défiler
contre le PACS
il y a à mon avis autant d'homosexuels
gauche
on peut considérer que c'est un choix de
vie privée qui ne regarde que la
personne et que le PACS quelque chose
qui est destiné à rendre public ce choix
et qu'on n'accepte pas comme tel rien
l'homophobie c'est une chose condamnable
le refus du PACS c'est autre chose il y
a deux aspects vous parliez de ce député
qui a défilé à cette manifestation on
fait moi si vous voulez mon avis sur sur
son comportement je le plains je le
plains parce que quand on est obligé
pour soigner son électorat d'aller
manifester contre contre soi-même contre
contre ce qu'on est même si on veut
l'enfuir l'enfouir contre la contre nos
propres différences
c'est dramatique ceci dit je n'avais pas
eu l'occasion d'en discuter avec lui et
j'espère qu'un jour j'aurai l'occasion
d'en discuter avec lui et je
m'arrangerai dans un bar je m'arrangerai
qu'il n'y ait pas de caméra de
télévision ou quoi que ce soit parce que
j'ai pas envie de lui porter tort mais
je lui expliquerai mon point de vue ceci
dit je ne suis pas non plus pour
ce qu'a proposé à Cup c'est à dire de
forcer
ils disent eux-mêmes voilà je suis
homosexuel est-ce que vous avez fait
vous êtes le premier encore une fois à
droite homme politique de droite et
l'avoir fait soit il y a la balance
c'est ce que proposer acte un moment là
à outing c'est à dire on les dénonce moi
quand j'ai entendu donc cette
cette envie d'acteur de thé ce député ça
m'a fait penser tout de suite je me suis
remémoré les images que j'ai vu à la
télévision de ce qui s'est passé pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale c'est-à-dire
que on envoyait dans des camps de la
mort des juifs avec des étoiles jaunes
en envoyait des homosexuels dans les
chambres à gaz avec des étoiles roses et
ces gens en les envoyait là-bas sur
dénonciation très bien merci beaucoup
merci de votre témoignage
je voudrais si vous me le permettez
rajouter un mot parce que tout à l'heure
j'étais j'attendais donc pour venir sur
le plateau et on m'a transmis un fax
d'insultes sur lequel on me menaçait de
dénoncer un certain nombre de choses
supplémentaires sur ma vie
alors si vous me le permettez j'ai deux
trois choses à dire il me semble que
certaines personnes n'ont pas compris ce
qu'il y a motivé cette démarche là on me
reproche d'avoir voulu m'en servir à des
fins politiciennes je voudrais bien que
les gens comprennent que quand on est de
droite et qu'on veut plaire à un
électorat de droite on dit on dit ce que
les gens de droite ont envie d'entendre
et on fait ce que les gens de droite ont
envie qu'on fasse et le problème c'est
que je n'ai pas du tout fait ça pour ça
je l'ai fait pour moi et je l'ai fait
parce que j'en ai assez d'évoluer dans
un milieu où règne l'hypocrisie et je
vais vous dire une chose que j'avais
décidé de ne pas dire parce que je
souhaitais protéger une personne il y a
trois ans j'ai voulu faire ce que nombre
de politiciens font c'est-à-dire vouloir
mentir et je me suis marié je me suis
marié parce que j'avais le sentiment que
ça protégerait ça me protégerait de tout
ça et je me suis rendu compte à un
moment donné que c'était pas la solution
parce que je m'enfermais dans un
mensonge qui était difficilement
supportable et j'en ai discuté avec un
certain nombre de personnes il se trouve
aussi que j'ai pu en discuter avec pas
mal d'homosexuels parce que sur Bordeaux
j'ai des parts dans un établissement qui
est fréquenté par par des homosexuels
donc j'ai pu en discuter avec eux et
l'ensemble des informations que j'ai
recueillies le mal-être que j'ai pu
percevoir par ces gens-là le malheur la
solitude qui que j'ai ressenti
m'a fait me promettre à moi-même que
dorénavant je ne mentirai plus que si je
fais de la politique et j'en fais par
passion et pour des convictions et que
donc si les électeurs veulent que je
travaille pour eux il faudra qu'ils me
prenne comme je suis avec mes défauts
mes qualités et je pense que c'est avec
des gestes comme ça que on peut redonner
parce que tout à fait clairement ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire là
maintenant vous vous dites aux gens qui
essayent encore maintenant malgré votre
coming out de vous faire chanter vous
leur dites donc
c'est vrai je me suis marié c'est vrai
que j'ai une agence immobilière à
Bordeaux et que j'ai des parts dans un
établissement fréquenté par des
homosexuels donc n'essayez pas de me
faire chanter avec ça je le dis à la
télé voilà c'est fini
bravo merci merci beaucoup
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu